hey it stays for recent TV I am hanging
here outside of the Target Center in
Minneapolis Minnesota I'm here this week
for the Republican National Convention
so I came here tonight because there was
a concert the band Rage Against the
Machine which is a very political and
provocative band was jamming away in
here and a lot of the the folks in town
a lot of the police and the news media
thought that this could be potentially a
really bad situation when the concert
ended because raids would sort of
provoke people to do things to to break
stuff to riot to protest to be to become
violent if these cops weren't here no
one approached us because there would be
no one to listen to the protest
in my speech I think they're all just an
all-black you know they're they're
trying to look as intimidating as
possible and when people feel
intimidated that's when people rebelling
and act out you know what I mean she was
a very bizarre bizarre scene you
basically have three groups here you
have the news media you have the cops
and you have the concert goes so the
concert ends there's a bunch of yelling
when they first come out but then
basically I think everyone was just
really impressed by the uniforms of the
cops which is kind of funny cuz everyone
just started taking pictures of the cops
because they look cool so we had a
million people taking cellphone pictures
nobody protesting but everybody feeling
like something needed to happen like
somebody needed to get arrested if
somebody needed to break something well
clearly they're a political band but
besides music the only thing that they
promoted throughout the whole concert
was a peaceful protest a non-violent
voice your opinion let the government
know what you think but don't take it
any further than then
nobody is died for us people will see
the the television coverage and all this
and all they're seen is two cops dressed
in all black and right looking
intimidating as all hell
people chanting and it looks everyone
knows how it looks it looks bacon here
tonight for a reason TV I'm Dan Hayes
have a good one there's no reason hey
there's no reason for these cops why
don't I see can we see my tax money on
cops being there for no reason stupid